Now let’s turn our attention
to control hazards,
illustrated by the code
fragment shown here.
Which instruction should
be executed after the BNE?
If the value in R3 is non-zero,
ADDC should be executed.
If the value in R3 is zero, the
next instruction should be SUB.
If the current instruction is
an explicit transfer of control
(i.e., JMPs or branches), the
choice of the next instruction
depends on the execution
of the current instruction.
What are the implications
of this dependency
on our execution pipeline?
How does the unpipelined
implementation
determine the next instruction?
For branches (BEQ
or BNE), the value
to be loaded into the
program counter depends on
(1) the opcode, i.e.,
whether the instruction
is a BEQ or a BNE,
(2) the current value of the
program counter since that’s
used in the offset
calculation, and
(3) the value stored in the
register specified by the RA
field of the instruction
since that’s the value tested
by the branch.
For JMP instructions, the next
value of the program counter
depends once again on the opcode
field and the value of the RA
register.
For all other instructions,
the next PC value depends only
the opcode of the instruction
and the value PC+4.
Exceptions also change
the program counter.
We’ll deal with them
later in the lecture.
The control hazard is
triggered by JMP and branches
since their execution depends
on the value in the RA register,
i.e., they need to read from
the register file, which happens
in the RF pipeline stage.
Our bypass mechanisms ensure
that we’ll use the correct
value for the RA register
even if it’s not yet written
into the register file.
What we’re concerned about
here is that the address
of the instruction following
the JMP or branch will be loaded
into program counter at the
end of the cycle when the JMP
or branch is in the RF stage.
But what should the IF stage
be doing while all this is
going on in RF stage?
The answer is that in the case
of JMPs and taken branches,
we don’t know what the IF stage
should be doing until those
instructions are able to access
the value of the RA register
in the RF stage.
One solution is to stall the
IF stage until the RF stage can
compute the necessary result.
This was the first of
our general strategies
for dealing with hazards.
How would this work?
If the opcode in the RF
stage is JMP, BEQ, or BNE,
stall the IF stage
for one cycle.
In the example code shown here,
assume that the value in R3
is non-zero when the
BNE is executed, i.e.,
that the instruction
following BNE
should be the ADDC at
the top of the loop.
The pipeline diagram shows the
effect we’re trying to achieve:
a NOP is inserted into the
pipeline in cycles 4 and 8.
Then execution resumes
in the next cycle
after the RF stage determines
what instruction comes next.
Note, by the way, that we’re
relying on our bypass logic
to deliver the correct value
for R3 from the MEM stage since
the ADDC instruction that
wrote into R3 is still
in the pipeline, i.e., we have
a data hazard to deal with too!
Looking at, say, the WB stage
in the pipeline diagram,
we see it takes 4 cycles
to execute one iteration
of our 3-instruction loop.
So the effective CPI is
4/3, an increase of 33%.
Using stall to deal
with control hazards
has had an impact on the
instruction throughput
of our execution pipeline.
We’ve already seen the logic
needed to introduce NOPs
into the pipeline.
In this case, we add a mux
to the instruction path
in the IF stage, controlled
by the IRSrc_IF signal.
We use the superscript
on the control
signals to indicate which
pipeline stage holds
the logic they control.
If the opcode in the RF
stage is JMP, BEQ, or BNE
we set IRSrc_IF
to 1, which causes
a NOP to replace the
instruction that was
being read from main memory.
And, of course, we’ll be setting
the PCSEL control signals
to select the correct
next PC value,
so the IF stage will fetch the
desired follow-on instruction
in the next cycle.
If we replace an
instruction with NOP,
we say we “annulled”
the instruction.
The branch instructions
in the Beta ISA
make their branch
decision in the RF stage
since they only need the
value in register RA.
But suppose the ISA had a branch
where the branch decision was
made in ALU stage.
When the branch decision
is made in the ALU stage,
we need to introduce two
NOPs into the pipeline,
replacing the now unwanted
instructions in the RF and IF
stages.
This would increase the
effective CPI even further.
But the tradeoff is that
the more complex branches
may reduce the number of
instructions in the program.
If we annul instructions in all
the earlier pipeline stages,
this is called
“flushing the pipeline”.
Since flushing the pipeline has
a big impact on the effective
CPI, we do it when it’s the
only way to ensure the correct
behavior of the
execution pipeline.
We can be smarter
about when we choose
to flush the pipeline
when executing branches.
If the branch is not
taken, it turns out
that the pipeline has
been doing the right thing
by fetching the instruction
following the branch.
Starting execution of an
instruction even when we’re
unsure whether we really
want it executed is called
“speculation”.
Speculative execution is
okay if we’re able to annul
the instruction before it has an
effect on the CPU state, e.g.,
by writing into the register
file or main memory.
Since these state changes
(called “side effects”) happen
in the later pipeline stages,
an instruction can progress
through the IF, RF, and ALU
stages before we have to make
a final decision about
whether it should be annulled.
How does speculation help
with control hazards?
Guessing that the next value of
the program counter is PC+4 is
correct for all but
JMPs and taken branches.
Here’s our example again, but
this time let’s assume that
the BNE is not taken, i.e.,
that the value in R3 is zero.
The SUB instruction
enters the pipeline
at the start of cycle 4.
At the end of cycle 4,
we know whether or not
to annul the SUB.
If the branch is
not taken, we want
to execute the SUB
instruction, so we just
let it continue
down the pipeline.
In other words, instead
of always annulling
the instruction
following branch,
we only annul it if
the branch was taken.
If the branch is not
taken, the pipeline
has speculated correctly
and no instructions
need to be annulled.
However if the BNE
is taken, the SUB
is annulled at
the end of cycle 4
and a NOP is
executed in cycle 5.
So we only introduce a bubble
in the pipeline when there’s
a taken branch.
Fewer bubbles will decrease
the impact of annulment
on the effective CPI.
We’ll be using the same data
path circuitry as before,
we’ll just be a bit more
clever about when the value
of the IRSrc_IF control
signal is set to 1.
Instead of setting it
to 1 for all branches,
we only set it to 1 when
the branch is taken.
Our naive strategy of always
speculating that the next
instruction comes from PC+4
is wrong for JMPs and taken
branches.
Looking at simulated
execution traces,
we’ll see that this error in
speculation leads to about 10%
higher effective CPI.
Can we do better?
This is an important question
for CPUs with deep pipelines.
For example, Intel’s Nehalem
processor from 2009 resolves
the more complex x86 branch
instructions quite late
in the pipeline.
complications of dealing with R31.
What if there are multiple matches, i.e.,
if the RF stage is trying to read a register
that's the destination for, say, the instructions
in both the ALU and MEM stages?
No problem!
We want to select the result from the most
recent instruction, so we'd chose the ALU
match if there is one, then the MEM match,
then the WB match, then, finally, the output
of the register file.
Here's diagram showing all the bypass paths
we'll need.
Note that branches and jumps write their PC+4
value into the register file, so we'll need
to bypass from the PC+4 values in the various
stages as well as the ALU values.
Note that the bypassing is happening at the
end of the cycle, e.g., after the ALU has
computed its answer.
To accommodate the extra t_PD of the bypass
mux, we'll have to extend the clock period
by a small amount.
So once again there's a design tradeoff - the
increased CPI of stalling vs the slightly
increased cycle time of bypassing.
And, of course, in the case of bypassing there's
the extra area needed for the necessary wiring
and muxes.
We can cut back on the costs by reducing the
amount of bypassing, say, to only bypassing
ALU results from the ALU stage and use stalling
to deal with all the other data hazards.
If we implement full bypassing, do we still
need the STALL logic?
As it turns out, we do!
There's one data hazard that bypassing doesn't
completely address.
Consider trying to immediately the use the
result of a LD instruction.
In the example shown here, the SUBC is trying
to use the value the immediately preceding
LD is writing to R2.
This is called a load-to-use hazard.
Recalling that LD data isn't available in
the data path until the cycle when LD reaches
the WB stage, even with full bypassing we'll
need to stall SUBC in the RF stage until cycle
5, introducing two NOPs into the pipeline.
Without bypassing from the WB stage, we need
to stall until cycle 6.
In summary, we have two strategies for dealing
with data hazards.
We can stall the IF and RF stages until the
register values needed by the instruction
in the RF stage are available in the register
file.
The required hardware is simple, but the NOPs
introduced into the pipeline waste CPU cycles
and result in an higher effective CPI.
Or we can use bypass paths to route the required
values to the RF stage assuming they exist
somewhere in the pipelined data path.
This approach requires more hardware than
stalling, but doesn't reduce the effective
CPI.
Even if we implement bypassing, we'll still
need stalls to deal with load-to-use hazards.
Can we keep adding pipeline stages in the
hopes of further reducing the clock period?
More pipeline stages mean more instructions
in the pipeline at the same time, which in
turn increases the chance of a data hazard
and the necessity of stalling, thus increasing
CPI.
Compilers can help reduce dependencies by
reorganizing the assembly language code they
produce.
Here's the load-to-use hazard example we saw
earlier.
Even with full bypassing, we'd need to stall
for 2 cycles.
But if the compiler (or assembly language
programmer!) notices that the MUL and XOR
instructions are independent of the SUBC instruction
and hence can be moved before the SUBC,
the dependency is now such that the LD is
naturally in the WB stage when the SUBC is
in the RF stage, so no stalls are needed.
This optimization only works when the compiler
can find independent instructions to move
around.
Unfortunately there are plenty of programs
where such instructions are hard to find.
Then there's one final approach we could take
-
change the ISA so that data hazards are part
of the ISA, i.e., just explain that writes
to the destination register happen with a
3-instruction delay!
If NOPs are needed, make the programmer add
them to the program.
Simplify the hardware at the "small" cost
of making the compilers work harder.
You can imagine exactly how much the compiler
writers will like this suggestion.
Not to mention assembly language programmers!
And you can change the ISA again when you
add more pipeline stages!
This is how a compiler writer views CPU architects
who unilaterally change the ISA to save a
few logic gates :)
The bottom line is that successful ISAs have
very long lifetimes and so shouldn't include
tradeoffs driven by short-term implementation
considerations.
Best not to go there.